sunday is going to mark 20 years since
elizabeth smart was kidnapped from her
bedroom at knifepoint in salt lake city
she was 14 at the time and survived nine
months in captivity
since then she has worked to help other
survivors of abuse she started the
elizabeth smart foundation which joined
forces with the malou foundation earlier
this year in april they hosted a summit
in salt lake city to fight child
exploitation and sex trafficking we
spoke with smart there in an exclusive
interview and she reflected on her
experience 20 years ago we have to warn
you here that some of the details are
disturbing
it was the beginning of the worst nine
months of my life
this morning a desperate search for a
kidnapped 14 year old utah girl in june
of 2002 the lives of elizabeth smart and
her family were changed forever
elizabeth one of six children was
sleeping in the same room as her
nine-year-old sister when a man broke
into the house and took her away here
you are 14 years old
supposedly in the safest place on earth
in your home in your bed
and you wake up and there's a man there
with a knife to your throat
and he takes you out of the home what
did you think was going to happen what
did you think this was
at first i don't even remember having
like thoughts of what it was in my mind
i mean i
like it was just complete shock
smart describes the horrific nine-month
ordeal that would follow
it took a terrible turn for you that
very first night yes well and i mean
after that my thoughts did go to he's
going to rape and kill me
and i even asked him that you asked him
i asked him um because as we got farther
up into the mountains i mean he took me
off any trail that we had been on
and um
i
i turned to him and i was like if you
are going to rape and kill me could you
do do it here because it was important
to me that my parents know what had
happened to me that they know that i
this wasn't my choice that they know
that i didn't run away and i wanted them
to find my body
and um so when i said that i mean i
remember him looking at me and smiling
and saying no i'm not going to do that
to you yet
yet yeah said that yeah
and that very very first night that's
exactly what i mean within the first
hour of being kidnapped and you said it
didn't stop with that one night no i
mean i was raped every day it got to the
point where i stopped thinking that i
had hit rock bottom because every time i
thought that he would come up with
something new
to make the situation situation worse i
mean for example the first day um he got
me up into this hidden camp um you know
he raped me
he chained me up
um i thought this is the worst nothing
could be worse than this
well the next day came
and he started laughing at me and then
he forced me to go naked all day while i
was still
chained up and
he
then thought it was even funnier to make
me watch him
have sex with his wife and be like this
is what you need to do you need to know
how a man and a woman how a married
couple have sex so you can do this to me
and if you don't you know you have to
stay naked
and you won't get anything to eat and
you won't get anything to drink and you
won't be able to sleep until you watch
this and until you fulfill me afterwards
so once he finished having sex with her
in front of me then he expected me to
perform in the same way
smart who was raised in a conservative
christian community says the trauma
didn't only affect her physically but
emotionally and spiritually too
i felt destroyed
what was your method on how you were
going to survive what did you do to
survive
i i mean the most important decision i
made
happened that first day that i was
kidnapped
i decided i was going to do
whatever it took it didn't matter what
it was i'd do whatever it took to
survive and in that thought process that
was followed up by if i don't want them
to kill me then
i should probably be as nice as i can
i should probably do everything that
they tell me because maybe if they do
that they'll like me and if they like me
surely it'll be harder to kill me you
know the phrase it's always used is
sometimes trauma survivors have
stockholm syndrome they've either
go along with their captors they're in
love with their captors
they they're brainwashed what do you say
to that i think that's a huge
misunderstanding i mean
how does a person if you really think
about it fall in love
with someone who is
mean with someone who is cruel you don't
most people have heard of fight or
flight
freeze is becoming more accepted but
many people have not heard of appease
yet and appease is it's not something
you maybe necessarily consciously think
about it's something that
you just automatically do and it's doing
what you have to do to survive
a startling end to the case of a utah
girl snatched from her home we're here
to announce officially that we have
found elizabeth smart it was such a
glorious day elizabeth when the news
broke that you were found and you were
found alive the prayers of the world
have brought elizabeth home
police were tipped off by eyewitnesses
who spotted smart and her captors near a
walmart in utah's salt lake valley a
police car pulled up and initially i
just thought it was like stopping a car
or doing something else
but then another one pulled up and
another one pulled up 48 hours
interviewed the police officers who
approached her she says
i think i know who you think i am but
i'm not that person
and we asked well who do you think we
think you are
and she says
that elizabeth's smart girl
and i'm not her he says one last time
let's let's put this to rest let's for a
peace of mind for yourself and your
family
tell me you're elizabeth smart she
stated
thou if thou sayest thou say it i
initially responded with thou sayest
because my captors thou sayest thou
sayest
um they were
still within earshot thou says means if
you say so you say so you're still
following what they told you so
in my mind it was admitting who i was
and even confirming it was scary i mean
i lived in a state of fear and terror
for nine months i was scared doing
anything and you said i i admitted i was
elizabeth smart and i actually remember
thinking that i made a mistake i mean
they put my hands behind my back and
handcuffed me
and put me in the back of the car
you were here i didn't know that yeah i
was handcuffed and i thought why did i
say that i guess i said the wrong thing
why would they handcuff me they must
think i'm lying or i've done something
wrong and
i mean
in their defense
i
i honestly don't think
that anyone had ever been in that
situation before
i don't think there was a best practices
back then i don't think anyone thought i
was going to come back alive
and smart says to this day her parents
have not asked her details about her
time in captivity
never
never in
the you know the 20 years
since i was kidnapped have they ever sat
there and been like
tell me what happened
as an adult and a parent myself
and an advocate and a survivor
i look back and actually i feel
a deep gratitude
that they did not
pressure me into telling them anything
today elizabeth smart is focused on
educating the public about sexual
assault and exploitation and spending
time with her family she has been
married for 10 years and has three
children
despite everything would you say life is
good for elizabeth smart yes
i would say life is beautiful for
elizabeth smart there's my life's not
perfect no i mean my life's a hot mess a
lot of the time
um you know my family is not perfect um
but
i i am happy because even beyond all of
our imperfections all of our
hot messes um i am surrounded by people
who i love more than anything in the
world and who i know love me
yeah she's deeply loved you know the
couple that kidnapped her wanda barzi
the wife spent more than 15 years in
prison before she was released in 2018.
her husband that's brian david mitchell
remains in prison serving a life
sentence i just marvel at her guys her
composer that she can talk coherently
about it that she's poised because you
know there are more details of the case
that you know you can't share on
television but what she went through to
be able to come out on the other side
evil is so profound the evil is so
profound so is our understanding of the
world after going through something like
that no and when she said that her
parents never asked her anything i was a
little surprised at that because i'm
thinking i would at least ask and if if
my daughter said i don't want to talk
about it i would i would back away but
she said no and she's glad they handled
it that way right they allowed her to
talk about it when she was ready to talk
about and her mother told her when she
came back and this is what helped her he
took nine months of your life don't let
him take another day from you he took
nine months don't let him take another
day and i was curious about her falling
in love and finding intimacy and she
said i could do that gail because it was
my choice
there's a difference i know the
difference between rape and i know the
difference between true love and i could
fall in love with the man that she has
married because it was my choice yeah
she's she's remarkable after dealing
with so much trauma i'm glad she's
speaking about it me too kidnappings
happen all of the time she will help
many people yeah